- Hey, Pat just said
we look like the cheerleaders
from "The Longest Yard."
- Whoo!
- Hey! Keep the foot
on the gas!
- You better call
the National Guard.
- I don't see
not one touchdown up there.
- Hey, we done kicked they ass.
They need some help.
- What they gonna say now?
Doubted us three weeks in a row.
- [Rob Gronkowski:] I'm like,
"Oh, this is reminding me
of, like, back in the day."
- Hey, y'all already got a ring.
It's our turn, bro.
We'll see y'all next year.
- Welcome
to the playoffs, baby.
- Hey, these games
ain't for everybody!
These games for the elite!
- Just give all you got!
- [Tony Romo:]
This is gonna be awesome.
Tom Brady. Patrick Mahomes.
Generation against generation.
Oh, this is huge.
- Hey, we on the beach today, huh?
- Huh?
- We on the beach today.
You see it. Huh? You see us.
- Argh!
Wish we were in Tampa.
- Go, Bucs!
- [Patrick Mahomes:] Hey, we worked all year
for this moment right here!
Play together! Play fast!
Let's dominate a football game!
- How 'bout them...
- [Together:] Chiefs?!
- Ribs are done.
Beer’s in the fridge.
The Bucs are on TV.
- Let's go!
- [LeSean McCoy:] I'll take you down right now.
- How you doin’,
huh? Two in a row, man.
- Let's go, baby.
- [Tom Brady:] Have a great night, baby.
- [Bruce Arians:] Have a great one, man.
- Yeah, you too.
- This is it right here, huh?
This is it right here.
- Hey. There ain't no
bigger stage than this, man!
- What's up with you?
- [Jim Nantz:]
This could be one for the ages.
- [Romo:] Ohh,
I see what you did there.
This is a matchup
that we're gonna be
talking about for a long time.
- Been here before, baby.
Do what we do.
One play at a time.
- This is why you wanna play
the game your whole life, bro.
- Yeah.
- For this moment right here.
We gotta take advantage
of the opportunity now.
- Whoo!
Hot diggity dog!
- That was tight.
- That oughta get you
a little fired up.
[Whistle blowing]
- [Sarah Thomas:] You're good!
- [Announcer:]
Here is the approach.
Toe hits leather.
- [Nantz:]
Super Bowl LV is under way.
- Here we go, D!
- Yes, sir!
- Yeah, I'm comin'.
- All day, 55! Yes, sir! Yes, sir!
- Shark! Shark attack!
♪♪♪
- [Announcer:] Knocked down!
- Ahhhh!
- That is Pierre-Paul.
♪♪♪
- Yeah. Yeah.
- Hey.
- Yeah. Yeah!
- Hut hut!
- [Nantz:] 3rd-and-11.
Pressure again. Mahomes.
Look at this throw.
And almost pulled in!
- [Romo:] Great defense
on the back end.
- Let's go!
- [Mitch Holthus:]
49-yard attempt by Butker.
And he's got it.
3-0, Kansas City.
- [Brady:] Let's go, boys.
- Let’s get it.
- Win one play
at a time, huh?
- Go, Tommy.
- [Announcer:]
The Bucs are in the red zone.
- [Nantz:] Here's Brady's pass.
It's Gronkowski!
The biggest tandem
for touchdowns
now in postseason history.
- Let's fire the damn cannons.
[Cannon sounds]
- That's my dawg, Robby G.
Big G. That's the Big G.
- [Nantz:] 3rd-and-8.
- [Holthus:] And the Kansas City Chiefs
are struggling on third down.
- [Nantz:]
Oh, and it's dropped by Kelce.
- [Romo:] Watch Mahomes.
He's gonna get pressured.
And that is costly.
- Yeah!
You kill that edge, baby.
- Let's go!
- Yeah.
- [Holthus:]
And the Buccaneers knocking
on the door again, leading 7-3.
Long count by Brady.
They fake on the run.
They throw it left. Wide open.
Knocked away at the last second.
They went to Joe Haeg.
- [Announcer:] That's why he's
an offensive tackle.
- He’s just gotta catch and fall.
He don’t know.
He gotta catch and fall.
- [Holthus:] Fourth down.
- I go for it, man. Why not?
- [Announcer:] Bucs are
gonna go for it on fourth down.
- Come on, D!
- [Romo:] You need touchdowns
when you have the chance
to get in.
- [Holthus:] Ronald Jones Jr.
He is pushed back.
Did he get across the goal line?
- Touchdown!
- No! No! No!
- Yeah! Let's go!
- [Frank Clark:] What's happenin'?
- [Tyrann Mathieu:] Turnovers so big
in these games.
- [Holthus:]
Brady standing tall.
Pass knocked down.
Intercepted off the deflection!
Pending the penalty that was
in the Chiefs secondary.
Interception on 3rd-and-4
wiped out.
They're gonna call Charvarius
Ward with a holding penalty.
- Defense is playing great.
Let's score for ‘em right here.
- [Announcer:] Play-action fake.
Brady looking. Brady looking.
Looking, looking.
Throws toward the end zone.
Caught ball!
Touchdown, Tampa Bay Buccaneers!
- Let's go!
- [Announcer:]
Rob Gronkowski's got two today!
- [Gronkowski:] I was like, "Finally."
- [Tanner Hudson:] Yeah. Hey,
good time to do it.
- [Gronkowski:] Yeah. I'm like,
"Oh, this is reminding me
of, like, back in the day."
- [Mike Evans:] Let's go, AB.
Let's go, Lenny.
- Come on, D!
- [Announcer:] Buccaneers
line up at the 1-yard line.
10 seconds on the clock.
Brady. Play-action fake. Looks
toward the right, throws—
- Touchdown!
- Whoo!
- That's why
you don't get scared, baby!
- [Announcer:] Very unfortunate,
undisciplined play
by the Chiefs defense.
- [Nantz:]
Fournette. Fournette!
- Go, Leonard!
Look at Lenny get on that horse!
It's a Bucs life up in here, baby!
- I didn't score cuz
I wanted you to score.
- Robby G, my dawg.
- Because I love Lenny the Third!
- Bro, that's
a physical-ass drive.
You see Lenny on that drive?
- Gotta score a touchdown.
- Let's go! Let's turn up!
- Go get it now!
- Hut, hut!
- [Nantz:] 4th-and-9.
Running for his life.
Mahomes got it away!
Incomplete.
- [Chris Godwin:] Yo, he is a magician.
I'm convinced.
- [Evans:] Mahomes is unbelievable.
- [Romo:] Trying to do
anything to help his team
and taking a huge shot.
- Keep fighting, baby!
Just keep fighting!
- Turnover, it's over.
Turnover, and it's over!
- Hut!
- [Announcer:] Here's the snap.
Mahomes running to his right.
Look out. He may run.
Mahomes directing—
throws toward the end zone.
Batted away. Intercepted!
Devin White!
- Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes!
- [Announcer:] Bucs are
the Super Bowl champs.
- Champa Bay!
Held the No. 1 offense
to zero touchdowns!
- Kansas City needs some help.
- Help is on the way!
- We done kicked they ass.
They need some help.
- Hell of a season, dawg.
We'll be back. We'll be back.
- Hey, y'all already got a ring.
It's our turn, bro.
We'll see y'all next year.
- Congrats. You deserve it, man.
- Thanks, brother. You do, too.
- So happy for you. Way to go.
- Ohh! Yeah!
- Let me see—ahh!
- Two tuddies.
- Two tuddies!
- I was saving up
for the Super Bowl.
- You did it! Ohh!
You balled out, baby.
- You balled out, too, bro.
- Way to go.
- Man, I love you.
Greatest of all time, man.
I love you, man.
Thank you so much.
- It's what we wanted.
- [Announcer:]
We're the champions of the world!
Tom Brady, you are the man.
You are the GOAT,
the greatest of all time.
- We won, man.
Do you know what that means?
We get a ring.
- Champions! Yeahhh!
- Ahhhhh!
- People keep
calling me bandwagon.
Does this look like
bandwagon gear to y'all?
- Yeah! Tampa Bay
just won the Super Bowl.
Chad, what are we gonna do?
- Gosh! I am,
I am a wave of emotion!
I'm getting dizzy from spinning.
- Disney World!
- And how long
we been Bucs fans?
- Since Day 1.
The Dreamsicle days, baby!
- Let's go!